welcome back to the Rich Eisen show
pleased to have back here in studio love
everything that she does and I'm gonna
stop talking about it like she's not
sitting here to my right whose line is
it anyway the host of whose line is it
anyway currently in season 13 Criminal
Minds season 13 premieres Wednesday at
10:00 p.m. Eastern on CBS which is
America's most watched Network I do
believe and the voice of Lara Cain Alana
cane in Archer mm-hmm Aisha Tyler good
to see you
hey thanks for having me back and of
course there's the movie new film axis
that opened up in Los Angeles last
Friday and in New York on this coming
Friday they directed which will we'll
get to in in a second so let me ask you
the 49ers are your team correct you love
the San Francisco was raised during the
drink the first dynasty so you said that
you stick with them in that yeah I don't
know I mean doesn't every doesn't every
like I mean look if you're an obsessive
then maybe of other reasons are
following a team but for me the team
that I watched with my dad as a kid is
always gonna be my team and that's your
team that's my so who's your was your
guys who is your guy
so who was your guy when you were
growing up when I was a kid yeah I mean
that was oh god that was Montana and
then Montana rice I mean that was like
that was it that was it
yes you know I've my father it's
interesting my father and I watched the
49ers coming up and you know that was
like a special time on the weekends for
us and then when rice went to Oakland my
father liked the Niners were dead to him
and they have remained dead damn really
yeah I I really feel like I like I wish
that rice had finished his career with
the 49ers there everything that he gave
to that so that team and I know that you
know everybody kind of focuses on
quarterbacks and quarter box you know
they're the stars of the team but it
just Maurice was he's one of the
greatest people to ever play the game
and it just felt it felt like an
ignominious end to his career that he
didn't get to finish well he's
absolutely and I've been fortunate to be
around a ton of them mm-hmm the the
nastiest competitor I've ever seen he
couldn't he can't let things go Mike
I once did a Pro Bowl segment with him
and Emmitt Smith mhm
together and I to segment interview
where I threw two breaks in we're gonna
come right back to Dancing with the
Stars veterans
one of them one and the other one didn't
right I'll be right back I laughed and
Jerry where I spent the next two minutes
during the commercial breaks tearing a
hole through no way Wow tearing a hole
through me and I'm like okay so how many
how many seconds do we come back right
one of the greatest what a greatest I
was upset about not winning dancing
because I'm like dude you are you've got
every record ever ever or the greatest
ever
there's no question greatest ever
there's no question there's a question
with him and Jim Brown as to who's like
maybe the greatest to ever wear a
uniform and even that he was just pissed
it I do it's interesting though like I
interviewed like vivid some athletes on
my podcast and a girl on girl girl on
guy podcast yeah and um oh god his
name's not in my head because it's early
in the morning and Avenue you know I'm
having a stroke it come to me in a
minute I just like an ongoing low-level
stroke Lakers pretty boy married to
Vanessa Williams Rick Fox Rika's gonna
he's gonna punch me in the next
interview next time sick [ __ ] I live I
legitimately am I just had like had like
a total brain blank um okay Rick was
talking about the fact that athletes are
competitive in every aspect their lives
right and like on the field off the
field they said if if that guy pulls up
in a Maserati then you're gonna pull up
in a Bugatti like if that guy's got
seven buttons on his suit you're gonna
come back with a 31 button seems like
you know what I mean like it's just
always competition so I guess it makes
sense that he would have been upset with
you right but it's also incredibly silly
right but aren't comics like that - I
know so you know I mean I guess on some
level we're competitive I mean if I'm
going up after you I'm gonna make sure
that you know I'm get more laughs than
you and if I go up before you I'm gonna
make sure I destroy the audience so that
you have nothing left
no one can laugh but I do think we also
secretly support each other because you
don't know how hard it is to be a comic
the best thing that they think comedians
do would say this kind of like sidelong
schadenfreude is support where if you
tell a joke that's funny I won't laugh
at it but I will make a noise that
resembles a laugh in some way to
indicate my - oh you should Tyler here
in the Rich Eisen show I did stand-up in
college awesome I don't know three years
that's so great
this thing I've ever had to do it's very
I mean I've done a lot of live
broadcasts in my day uh nothing compares
to standing in front of an audience try
to make him laugh or figure out what to
be said from your repertoire right
connects right and make it work so I
thought you know imma try this mmm and I
did it in a student union in Michigan
when stand-up comedy in the late 80s was
red-hot Tom Hanks and Sally Field were
making movies about it you know and so I
then went on the road and it was the
toughest thing I had to do and the
comics after we were off I would start
you know havin fun telling jokes and
they would basically make that noise
yeah that you said like that or just
like how you gonna or they say you're
gonna use that Oh God Thievery how are
you going to use that and I'm like I
don't know if I'm cut out I also don't
allow comics to do material on me unless
we've agreed that it's material time do
you know like if we if we sat down and
I'm like I'll give you five minutes to
try some stuff out I'll be fine but if
you're just like trying to sneak bits
into the conversation and like you're
doing a bit right now buddy cuz cuz I
don't work here yeah there's no stealth
workshop no no no no no and no you can't
you can't sneak up on another comedian
with your bit about flying right you
don't mean but did we come up with a bit
with tiny man couch I was just
commenting on myself I understand but
there's something that could make you
classy to take the tiny man couch bit
away from the tiny man kappa i'm only
gonna use my tiny man cash but when i
hear at the Rich Eisen show never
anywhere else so it is a very small
couch it is a certainly small couch but
one that but there are those that love
it well one that management providers
and it's wildly masculine they're like I
don't know how it could be anyway you
can't tell you can't see at home but
there's actually it's got a beard just
hanging down just a giant it's such a
manly couch the new film axis you were
here the last time talking about a
Kickstarter campaign and now here it is
it stars an Irish actor named Emmett
Hughes who's an unknown here but it's
kind of like the edward burns of ireland
he made this beautiful small family
comedy called the O'Briens that
a lot of attention a couple years ago
and and I met him when I was over there
shadowing on a couple of shows on a show
called Vikings the people sure of course
yeah yeah and so he plays an actor who
had a great burst of success here in Los
Angeles and now isn't and the whole the
whole movies shot in the car yeah which
was a cool it was a really cool idea
like when I was trying to figure out
what my first film was gonna be I wanted
to do something that was gonna stand out
you know anything that was gonna be
different a lot of people that first
film is you know especially if it's a
small independent film it's like a bunch
of people talking in a room or you know
a family coming in a house and I just
wanted to do something that felt rugged
and different and and it was a cool set
of problems to solve how do you make a
movie about a guy driving through LA at
rush hour compelling and interesting and
exciting and and I mean I think we were
able to do that which is really fun and
people might know that there is another
movie that's very similar to this that I
wasn't filming with when I took the
movie on but I did see before we shot
ours called Locke but it took place at
night and the first thing I did when I
got this script is I'm doing this this
movie a daytime movie sure is we've got
this small set which is this car but
then we're gonna have this huge second
set which is all of LA so you really see
he drives from Elysian Park all the way
to the beach and you really see all of
Los Angeles and for anybody who lives
here Ellie's a character in the movie
it's a love letter to us Angeles and
everything that's beautiful and ugly
about it you know well Legion Park is
where Dodger Stadium is stadium features
prominently in my movie okay and so
thanks it's a dress yes so it starts on
like Vin Scully way and then winds up at
the ocean or it starts up you know this
beautiful kind of helipad above Dodger
Stadium looking down and and and you end
up in the Palisades as the Sun is
setting and so you just get to see all
of LA at that time that beautiful time
of day I wanted you know we all been in
our car stuck in our cart rush hour yes
it's a combination of rage and just you
know inexpressible fury and then this
kind of dreamy feel of what the sun's
kind of streaming through your car and
the dust boots are flying you got the
radio on and probably the last bit of
silence they're gonna give kids so it's
the only silence you can say probably
right and you're trying to handle a
little bit of business and also trying
to get a little bit of time alone and
and you like this kid I mean he's he's a
good guy you know he's done some pretty
bad things but he's not a bad person and
and I really like
he's about Redemption and the voices in
the movie are certainly recognizable
name's Sam Rockwell who did you go to
high school we went to high school
together we were in in theater class
together do you go to the prom well I
don't know if you can call it a prom I'm
probably just partied in the in the park
Adam Rodriguez Thomas Gibson paget
Brewster Geri Ferraro has been on the
show many many times yeah um how many
moms you put on the car to shoot the
coot the movie every we shot it we shot
this thing in seven days like I said we
shot every day driving from Elysian Park
to the beach in real time so we would
start around three o'clock and we'd end
around seven o'clock so that we were
shooting the movie every day the same
dialogue will be delivered at the same
point in LA at the same time of days
would all match we cut it together so we
have a had a beautiful mercedes-benz G
wagon and over yeah and and we put it up
on another truck so the actor didn't
have to drive and also deliver so there
was no 65 pages of dialogue well
actually yeah because I only you know I
we didn't have another foxy Irishman to
replace it with if those are in short
supply yeah there's only a few of them
running around so you didn't put actual
mom miles on the actual car but I will
tell you a fun thing fun story
we were driving we needed the whole cars
on this big process trailer and there's
lights and there's cameras and I'm
sitting up kind of behind it looking at
these monitors and this guy's acting
he's doing you know almost an entire
script all the way through every day by
himself and it's it's just hot it's just
hot testicular it like eating it eating
this in that car so at some point he
rolls down a window when we're at a
stoplight but the battery of the car has
died and to get and so now the window is
stuck down and it's not gonna match the
rest of the movie until we get it back
up and we're pulling on it we're tugging
on it and we have to pull over and
they've got a D rig three cameras and
this entire light array which is like
bolted to the front of the car
jumpstart the car and then reattach
everything which took us like an hour to
half and there's just all these photos
of me like standing in the middle of
traffic on Wilshire Boulevard with a
t-shirt that says welcome to the bleep
show the thong well these guys are
you know I can go back to the studio and
get more money you know name in lecture
on this movie when you see the credits I
am like eighteen credits it because I
was a director I was the sandwich maker
I was the hug Giver you know I mean I
was the PI was I was the neck puncher
like what I did everything that get this
movie made well it makes sense because
you do everything also like I said
Criminal Minds
Archer Kuragin Stone is a new line of
premium blended bottle cocktails for you
add Aisha Tyler on Twitter and and by
the way out of your where the side
effect of tiny man couch is that hot
it's testicular heat particular is known
as sweating balls you guys that's the
medical chart new Tennessee team name oh
please go cut be your new fantasy team
we started off two and one if we go on a
losing streak we have to change it to
hottest stick to the hot testicular heat
--mess that just sounds like a like a
fun night at a disco it just doesn't see
the glint in your eye too much back
there behind them your matrix setup so
amazing go check out axis at a theater
near you it's in Los Angeles and New
York for the time being check it all out
at Aisha Tyler on Twitter the Rich Eisen
show weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
isn't it amazing you can download an app
with your thumbprint you should download
our app with your thumbprint